they built layers of barricades around
Hong Kong's Airport thousands of them
blocking all the routes in and out for
most of the day a legal injunction meant
to stop demonstrators from entering the
airport made not a jot of difference
instead they made a mockery of the law
building walls out of whatever they
could lay their hands on inside
airport security struggled to track down
Aaron are suspected of being a protester
[Music]
tensions are high
riot police kept most from entering the
terminal itself but this campaign of
civil disobedience is taking many forms
travelers had to walk miles with about
40 flights canceled and many missing
them altogether
I think I'm gonna miss my flight by the
time the police arrived in numbers the
airport had already been seriously
disrupted the protesters immediately
withdrew walking to Tung Chung the
nearest town to the airport and inside
the subway station they set about
tearing it apart ticket machines were
smashed and the control room attacked
many of them used their umbrellas to
protect their identities
this was mob rule rightly storm trains
searching for demonstrators was parents
shielded their children it was over in a
flash but they draw terrible damage to
the station terminals getting into the
train station they flooded the area with
water they broke into a fire
extinguisher and they've trashed
everything everywhere the protestors
went they built barricades to try to
slow the progress of the police and a
nearby construction site provided them
with plenty of materials in one corner
they were turning traffic signs into
shields several barricades were set
alight the pro-democracy protests are
not going away
the police do not seem to be able to get
a grip of this rising anarchy
arriving at the station hours afterwards
with no protestor in sight
there's a lot of anger towards the
police - those are boos and jeers from
the residents as the police leave the
station and the demonstrators are
getting increasingly angry and violent
as their frustration grows Alex Warford
Sky News Hong Kong